hey everyone it's Sarah with registered
nurse rn.com and in this video I'm going
to be talking about fine crackles so
fine crackles are sometimes referred to
as rels and the first thing what I want
to do is I want you to listen to an
example of what fine crackles may sound
like
now how do you know that you're hearing
fine crackles well you want to pay
attention to the timing with fine
crackles you're going to hear those
towards the end of inspiration and
they're going to be really brief you
also want to pay attention to that pitch
fine crackles are going to be high
pitched you also want to make sure that
they are discontinuous meaning that
you're able to distinguish those
individual popping cracking sounds that
are occurring in a series so they're
intermittent and these sounds tend to be
located in small Airways plus they're
going to have this defining
characteristic they're going to sound
very similar to popping or light
crackling of a fire and they cannot be
cleared with coughing and again let's
listen to that sample of fine crackles
foreign
now what's causing this sound well
whenever the patient breathes air into
those small Airways like the bronchioles
or the alveoli which are deflated or
collapsed it causes them to all of a
sudden crackle or explode open which
allows you to hear that high-pitched
crackling noise and Vine crackles can
occur in cases of congestive heart
failure actelectasis pneumonia and
pulmonary fibrosis okay so that wraps up
this video on fine crackles and don't
forget to access the link in the YouTube
description below which will give you
access to other videos in this
respiratory series